What do you like best or least about
your job? The editors of AEI's
Political Report have been exploring
workers answers. They find that most
workers are highly satisfied with most
aspects of their jobs. In a Gallup poll,
more than nine in ten employed people
said they were completely or somewhat
satisfied with the safety of their
workplace, their co-workers, and the
flexibility of their hours. Around 80
percent are satisfied with the amount of
work required of them, the recognition
they get on the job, and the amount of
vacation time they get. 81 percent are
even satisfied with their boss or
supervisor. In the poll, workers were
least satisfied about their health and
retirement benefits and on-the-job
stress, but even in these areas more than
two-thirds said they were satisfied.
Americans' views about the economy, their
jobs, and their futures are more positive
now than they have been in a long time.
In a new Bloomberg poll, nearly six in ten
said that they were moving closer to
their hopes for their careers and
finances. That's good news on Labor Day.
To learn more about my take on American
attitudes toward work, see the new issue
of AEI's Political Report. Also, let us
know what other topics you want our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.